Good, same, same technique, just with a change of direction — that's the so-called test figure-eight, or all tests with P2 designation.
There it's like this: we also start on an axis, we fly a completely closed left circle. In the test you always start with the left circle.
Then on our axis comes the directly attached right circle — that is, the two circles are flown offset a bit from each other, on a guide line, and that's why it's called the test figure-eight, because it looks like a shifted figure-eight.
It has nothing to do with the written figure-eight, it's two fully closed circles.
Pay attention too that once you've reached the axis — that is, on flight time — the direct change comes.
You shouldn't fly straight on this guide line and then have a change come — that always costs time.
So as soon as you have the axis, change.
You can also fly this manoeuvre with the brake at the loop in the hand or with the wrap.
Try both and take whichever you prefer.
Brake at the loop, we look for the minimum sink on both sides, we check the airspace, if it's clear, the left circle comes — weight left in, right hand all the way up.
Shortly before we're back on our heading, the body weight already comes — then on our heading the brake — and then comes the direct change, bang, into the right circle.
Then we finish the right circle almost completely; shortly before we're on our axis the body goes into neutral sitting position, and simultaneously but relaxed — so pull the outer brake always slowly, with feeling — then the outer brake comes,
so that we're braked on both sides.
Here too what's important first is not the time but simply the heading.
Heading — and the same applies for the double circle.
Heading is the first important thing, orientation in space, setting the bank angle, weight shift and so on.
The time comes later.
The more we've trained the whole thing, the more comfortable we feel when the bank angle is set a bit more.
And so we can adjust ourselves again.
And so we can focus more and more on that time.
If you fly the whole thing with half wrap, just pay attention that you don't brake too much.
We have a shorter steering travel, that is, look for minimum sink.
Bang, weight shift, set bank angle, then finish the circle almost completely.
Bang, weight neutral and the direct change over into the right circle.
And as soon as the right circle is almost completely closed, we go into the neutral sitting position.
Bang, take the outer brake along, so that we come out braked again.
Once we have that, we can then completely release the brake again too.
With the figure-eight it often happens that you initiate the first circle quite briskly.
Then the change comes and you mostly almost do a wingover onto that side and then run out of steam after the first input.
Bang, weight shift.
That means watch out that directly at the change you also work with the outer brake.
That means, when I go into here, bang, shortly before I'm on my heading, the outer hand comes harmonically with the weight,
so that I'm actually on my axis braked on both sides, and then comes the harmonic direct change.
OK, and there too always remember, outer brake.
Outer braking is an important element in paragliding.
If we end up in the spiral, for example, or just with the double circle in a very strong bank angle,
we'll never release the inner hand, but always pull the outer brake down far enough until we come straight out of the whole thing.
That's a very important element and that's what it's about.
For the figure-eight manoeuvre a prescribed flight axis is taken up.
Through measured pulling of the left brake line a left circle is flown, until the wing is back on the original flight axis.
With measured pulling of the right brake line a right circle is then flown, until the wing is back on the original flight axis.
Through measured braking, subsequent roll and pitch movements are caught and the wing is stabilised.
Caution! On the direction change, too strong pulling of the brake line or wrong timing can lead to a one-sided stall.
The time limit for the manoeuvre is a maximum of 25 seconds.
Important!
Time measurement only stops once the wing flies stably on the original flight axis.